AJA HAMMERLY: In
this Cloud Minute,
I'm going to show you
how to enable cloud
CDN for a backend service.
Cloud CDN works as part
of cloud load balancing.
I have a managed instance group
with a load balancer in front
of the instances already
set up in my project.
I turn on cloud CDN and
navigate to Networking.
Then I click on Load
Balancing and click Edit
on my load balancer.
Now I click Backend
Configuration,
click on my backend, and scroll
all the way to the bottom
and check the box
called Enable Cloud CDN.
Now I click Update
to save the changes.
Cloud CDN is enabled
and load balancing
will cache responses to
many requests at locations
all over the world.
To find out more about
which types of responses
can be cached, you
can find a link
to the documentation in
the video description.
I hope you found this
Cloud Minute helpful.